Tim what do you want to be as a boy as a  boy I wanted to be a pilot hard as part  of your training learning Russian and  retention of all the information your  biggest influence on me I think school  teachers in my teenage years best advice  you'll take to space enjoy the  experience what are you looking forward  to most the view of planet Earth what  will you miss most family what are you  taking to remind you of home I've got  some photos that will go my crew quarter  if you could take one thing that you're  not allowed to what would it be my wife  what scares you most not making it to  launch date favorite space food so far  bacon sarnie favorite space movie  interstellar next human mission Moon or  Mars moon do aliens exist yes it's more  like microbial life forms if you call  them alien pinterest you compete thank  you very much indeed